hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Freddy fazbear's pizzeria
simulator I hate everything about the
document results okay alright no I'm
looking at your primary in audio prompt
in 3 hi
that's a yes okay let me check my box
let's play test this bad boy ooh
best babe [ __ ] get the toilets are
clogged
somebody had to buy the exotic butters
over in there we gotta get those photos
gonna be fun and healthy Whoopie is $5
I see the [ __ ] Lucky's five dollars oh
why is it up available with my charm
pickles unavailable the gang's all here
we got big stir Ned Fred mr. hippo and
tiny crate cram bloom oh hey welcome to
the party
I shouldn't have known [ __ ] you just
snuck up on me piece of poo I'm so good
at the games
[Music]
hey guess what we're going on tour again
time to beat the dust out of these
raggedy bones we're gonna be going to
st. Louis and vertol Lake City gonna be
shooting a DVD special in Las Vegas Los
Angeles Phoenix San Diego San Francisco
Seattle against Portland
and not only that we're gonna be going
to Europe too we're going to the
Netherlands Paris Amsterdam Amsterdam
sorry let's go to Coba
you came five times lots of cities
Denmark Germany three times over wait we
done go to tour got markiplier come to
get a ticket right now or look in the
description every city is listed down
there and if you don't get it we're
never gonna be going on tour again so
you're gonna miss it
so if you haven't gotten a ticket
already go for it ask your parents if
you can go get them to buy a ticket for
you it's not too late for a Christmas
present check it out in the description
okay all right
[Music]